well it looks like Kang might actually
be leaving as in he may no longer be our
big bad of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and this would most likely mean based
off of reports that we have heard from
variety that Dr Doom would come into the
MCU and take his place now what's really
interesting is that no matter what
happens if Doom really does replace Kang
in the MCU as the big bad I don't think
Dr Doom is going to be attached to the
Fantastic for project at all and in fact
in the Multiverse Saga at least before
it ends he might not really be a
fantastic 4 villain but just an overall
Avengers villain which is fine because
literally in both iterations of Avengers
Secret Wars he's the villain and he
actually becomes God Emperor Doom which
is something that I really hope that we
see in the MCU and the way that they
could debut Dr Doom could be really
great because it would make him the big
bad of this Saga but it would also make
it to where he doesn't go away after
this Saga ends and he could stick around
for phase seven for phase 8 phase 9
however long Marvel Studios wants to
keep him around because we definitely
want Dr Doom in the MCU for a very long
time now as far as Marvel Studios
getting rid of Kang goes this was
reported a few days ago that Marvel
writer Jeff lovess who wrote Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania who was supposed
to write Avengers King Dynasty is no
longer attached to the project and
according to inside Joanna Robinson who
is one of the co-authors of MCU the
reign of Marvel Studios a book in which
they took the time to interview over a
hundred different people involved with
Marvel Studios to write the book she
came out and said that this is because
they are moving away from Kang in the
MCU and this came not too long after the
report from variety stating that Marvel
Studios might be considering replacing
King with Dr Doom and then yesterday it
was reported by deadline that Kang
Dynasty director Dustin Daniel keton
departs as the Director from The
Avengers film and now everybody is kind
of thinking the same thing that this
kind of confirms that they are indeed
moving away from Kang Dynasty and making
it a different Avengers film the writer
for the Kang movie is gone and the
director for the Kang movie is gone but
Dustin Daniel keton is sticking around
still to direct Shang Chi 2 and other
films and shows like Wonderman which is
kind of suspicious it makes us think
that they really did change the story
which is why he's no longer attached to
it it's not the same story so it does
kind of seem like that is what is
happening now how could this be possible
as far as the story and continuity goes
in the MCU well I've talked about it a
little bit in some other videos but
we'll dive in depth in this video and
it's actually quite simple and although
I do not want Kang or Jonathan Majors
out of the MCU the thought of Doom
coming in in a very specific way the way
that I believe they'll do it really does
excite me so let's first talk about Kang
it was revealed Reve a few months ago
that Kang was never really intended to
be the main big bad of the Multiverse
Saga and honestly in order to do all of
the stories that we've gotten so far in
the Multiverse Saga including the ones
that really connect to the Multiverse
like Loki Loki season 2 Spider-Man no
way home Kang did not actually have to
be the villain however what we learned
is that Kevin fogy once he saw Jonathan
Major's performance in Loki season 1 and
in Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
decided to make Kang the big bad because
he was so impressive and he was he was
amazing as he who remains in Loki season
1 he was also amazing as Victor timley
and he who remains again in Loki season
2 and he really was fantastic in Quantum
Mania there was some bad writing that
was involved with that movie that was
not his fault it's not Jonathan Major's
fault that they decided to have his
character be beaten by an army of ants a
man who has literally conquered entire
worlds multiple many worlds and killed
many Avengers so many that he forgot the
names of all the Avengers cuz they
Blended together was defeated by ants
terrible but that wasn't his fault the
point is he was awesome and every time
he was on the screen you really felt his
presence so Marvel took whatever plans
that they had originally for some big
bat in the MCU and they tossed them
aside and made Kang the main villain
then all of the stuff happened with
Jonathan major the actor who plays Kang
the Conqueror he was arrested and
charged with several cases of assault
against his now ex-girlfriend and he is
currently going to trial to defend
himself to prove that he is innocent
which him and his legal team have been
stated the entire time since this
happened in fact they have stated that
he is actually the victim and I've said
it before but kudos to Marvel Studios
for waiting to make a decision about him
instead of just firing him like some
other people did right when they heard
the allegations however and
unfortunately Jonathan Major's trial has
been pushed back and pushed back and
pushed back he's pretty much just like
the other projects on the MCU the
beginning of this trial has been pushed
back many times and Marvel Studios is
kind of pressed for time right now they
need to decide the direction of where
they're going to go with the MCU and it
sounds like they might have ran out of
time and decided to move on despite
whatever happens on the trial they may
have decided it's time so that begs the
question how exactly are they going to
get rid of Kang when they've set him up
in such a big way especially after Loki
season 2 well I've mentioned this before
but Loki season 2 actually leaves
everything pretty open literally for
anything to happen you could get rid of
Kang or dive further into the threat of
Kang the TVA now has one job monitor
Kang delete Kang prune kangs from these
timelines when he rises to power you can
go two ways with this one Kang is
becoming too strong there are too many
variants we can't monitor them all we
can't prune them all they have figured
out time travel they exist outside of
space and time now we can't monitor them
they're too strong a huge multiversal
war is coming we need to prepare an
Avengers team one that consists of
members of Heroes from every Universe
you can imagine that's one way you could
go and I would love to see this happen I
really would and if they decide to keep
King that is how it's going to happen
but if they decide to move away from
Kang then they simply state that the TVA
did an amazing job the TVA along with
the help of Loki is so good at their
jobs that anytime any type of Kang comes
to power or begins to come to power they
delete him right away they get rid of
them and the threat is gone it's pretty
simple and that would mean while they're
monitoring Kang they're not really
trying to look for anybody else that
could possibly be coming to power via
Multiverse travel or time travel enter
Dr Doom that is kind of a flaw of the
new TVA if you're only looking out for
Kang other threats could slip by but
here's the thing Dr Doom is one of the
smartest characters to ever exist in the
Marvel Universe he could definitely
understand time travel and keep in mind
Dr Doom doesn't necessarily have to be
from our 616 Universe in fact in the 838
Universe which we saw in Multiverse of
Madness that had Mr Fantastic of the
Fantastic 4 we saw Reed Richards use
some sort of a teleportation device so
clearly that Universe seemed to be a
little bit more advanced than ours so Dr
Doom could very well come from a
different universe as well in fact he
might even come from the 838 universe
itself and there's many ways you can do
this you can have him create the
technology himself you could have him
steal it from Reed Richards or you can
have him even steal it from Kang which
he kind of does in secret Wars he gets
the power of the beyonder and he
actually brings Kang back to life in one
of the secret War Stories so he can kind
of control time for him so there's a lot
of ways that they can bring in Doom here
however I don't think Doom is going to
come from the Fantastic 4 universe
because from what we've heard the
Fantastic 4 are also going to be coming
from a different Universe not the 616
Universe if the rumors are true and they
do this they set the Fantastic 4 movie
in a different Universe back in time in
the 60s then they should not bring in Dr
Doom from that Universe one the time
travel technology probably won't really
exist then unless he somehow got it from
Kang but from what we've heard about
kind of how the Fantastic 4 might end is
that they fail to save their universe
and the TVA basically shows up to save
them and they take them to the one
Universe where they're keeping all the
other saved Heroes if this happens
they're probably not saving Dr Doom and
the villain of the movie is reportedly
going to be galatis and some Heralds
which means Doom could come from a
different Universe which I really like
because he could go on to be the main
villain and he could be defeated but
then another variant of Doom could pop
up Post Secret Wars that way we don't
just get rid of him all of a sudden I
hope he goes on to be just like Loki I
hope he is the new Loki he shows up a
lot and gets better and better every
time you see him and ultimately could go
on to be a big bad again or you could
have him go back and forth between good
and bad there are a lot of stories to
where Doom actually chooses to fight
with the heroes and there's great
stories where he interacts with other
Heroes like doctor strange and him going
to the hell Dimension to try to save his
mother going to fight mafesto and since
Mesto is coming to the MCU I would
personally really love to see this story
or you could go straight up Secret Wars
comic route we heard that the main
villain of the Multiverse Saga the main
King Prime King was going to be sort of
a beyonder variant Kang and the beyonder
mixed into one well that would kind of
be perfect because you could just simply
introduce that variant soon and then
have Doom take his powers and become God
Emperor doom and then bam you're done he
is insanely powerful no one's stronger
than him no kings are stronger than him
him along with the TVA basically gets
rid of Kings but then the Multiverse has
a new problem they have God Emperor Doom
taking over and controlling the
Multiverse and that's where our Avengers
team would come together and go fight
him so as you can see it's very possible
and since the writer and the director
for Kang Dynasty have now left the
project the reports do seem to be backed
up now that Marvel Studios is simply
changing the project to not be Kang
focused so we could have an Avengers Dr
Doom movie on our hands pretty soon and
if this happens let me know what you
think about this I think it's
bittersweet I am really looking forward
to Jonathan majors and Kang and all the
variants being in secret Wars and Kang
Dynasty but if they move away Dr Doom is
a pretty great direction to move into
one of the greatest Marvel villains of
all time so let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof